hey everybody flickers of fear time once
again
this is a movie that i actually this is
really weird how this came about i
hadn't actually planned on doing this
one because i usually schedule these
ones like the recorded uh reviews
i usually schedule those like a month in
advance
and this was actually one that i hadn't
had on the schedule but then one night
when i was just kind of you know looking
for some [ __ ] to watch and i came across
this one i think it was on 2b for free
and i was kind of like oh man i never
really did get around to seeing that and
it's a clive barker adaptation and i had
heard like someone else talking about it
how it was really good and how it's kind
of underrated so i was like what the
hell i'm just gonna you know watch this
one and if it's good then i'll do a
flickers of fear on it i'll push it up
in the rotation uh this is the 2008 film
the midnight meat train
now as i said i had kind of heard
mixed reviews of it but i really did
want to see it because i remembered the
story which came out back in the early
80s i think it was 1984 it was in the
first volume of
books of blood
and i remember really liking the story
like some of the imagery from it really
stuck with me and i was interested to
see what the adaptation was like now
this was actually directed by ryu hey
kitamura which hopefully i'm pronouncing
that sort of correctly
who also
directed just fyi an excellent horror
thriller called down range
which i don't remember if we ever
reviewed it or not but it was on shutter
for a long time i don't know if it's on
there anymore and we just watched it at
random one time and it's really really
good uh so you know that's a
recommendation too it's called downrange
but it's the same director as the guy
that did this movie
and honestly i think this is like a
really good adaptation really one of the
best clive barker adaptations because
poor clive barker i guess because his
stories are so so fantastical that
it's really hard to translate them to
the screen without them looking kind of
shitty or without them looking
ridiculous or whatever like because he
just builds these whole like elaborate
worlds obviously hellraiser was a really
good adaptation um but other than that
some of the ones were just kind of like
okay like i rewatched lord of illusions
recently and that one was all right
um even though the book was a lot better
and so i so you know i'm always kind of
like maybe even more so than stephen
king adaptations i'm always kind of like
leery of clyde barker adaptations
because as much as i love clyde barker's
written stuff uh movie adaptations of
his never come out all that great
just just because like i said i think
they're too elaborate with the world
building and it's like unless you have
like a massive massive budget it's
really really difficult to
pull off i suppose but the nice thing
about the midnight meat train the story
that it's based on is actually if i
remember correctly it's actually really
really short and it's like pretty simple
it's not a huge i mean it's basically
just like a guy in a subway in new york
city and you know he sees a guy that
kills people and you know hangs him on
meat hooks and stuff like that and then
there's a little bit
of kind of like otherworldly kind of
[ __ ] at the end but it's nothing that
necessitates this big massive budget or
anything like that sadly the thing that
happened with this movie so
it went into production at lionsgate
and
i guess they spent some money on it
looks really nice actually the
cinematography is gorgeous and
everything like that but then by the
time that it was coming out the guy that
i guess there was a new guy like a new
new president at lionsgate
and
what seemed to have happened uh i don't
know if this is
really the case or if it's just
everyone's perception but what seemed to
have happened was that the movies that
had gone into production before he
became president he kind of gave those a
little bit of a short shrift
so that he could put stuff that he had
his name like on the production credit
so he could you know kind of push those
more and some of those movies were good
because one of those movies was the
strangers which is actually a really
good movie but movies like this one the
midnight meat train
that had gone into production under
someone else's uh you know auspices i
guess he just didn't really put too much
effort into it because this movie did
actually get a theatrical release but i
think it was only released into like a
hundred theaters and then it just kind
of like they just dumped it on dvd
so i think it was kind of like forgotten
about which is kind of a shame because
you know i it took me this long to get
around to seeing this movie like i said
it came back in 2008 and it was one of
those ones that i was like oh yeah i
keep meaning to watch that and i just
never got around to it and then i
finally did and i'm just kind of like
man that that was actually like a really
decent movie and a really decent
adaptation like i said the acting was
really good the cinematography was
really good the only thing i can kind of
dang it for was like the cgi was a
little in but you know a lot of it was
in 2008 so i'm not gonna you know give
it that much of uh you know hassle about
that but um and i liked the way they
expanded it uh greatly it has like the
same core of the story as the clive
barker one does but obviously because
this short story is so short and
basically it's just kind of like one
incident
so they had to kind of like expand it
out and i think they did a really good
job doing that kind of like expanding
the world out
so what we have is we have a guy named
leon who's played by bradley cooper now
this i believe was prior to him being
really really famous because he's really
famous now right because wasn't he in a
star is born and stuff like i mean that
was the most recent thing that i saw him
in but it's like yeah he's massively
famous now but this was i didn't even
realize it was him like when i first saw
it when i first saw this movie and then
at the end i'm like oh it's that guy um
interestingly i don't know if they did
this on purpose i kind of feel like
maybe they did
but bradley cooper in this movie
looks a lot like clive barker when he
was young so it so it's almost kind of
like they were making like a little sly
winking like hey it kind of looks like
because from some angles i was like god
that looks very much like a young clive
barker like like he looked back in the
80s so i just thought that was kind of
funny maybe it's a coincidence i don't
really know
but so yeah bradley cooper plays uh leon
now leon is a photographer he lives in
new york city with his girlfriend
and he's basically like a street
photographer he's fascinated by new york
city he's fascinated by like the
grittiness of it the griminess of it and
he's always trying to like capture
sort of like the essence of the city i
guess in his photographs and uh as the
story starts i guess him and his
girlfriend live in this apartment his
girlfriend seems to work like she works
at a diner or something like that and he
um basically makes money by taking
pictures of stuff and like selling them
to tabloids and newspapers and things
like that so he's a freelance
photographer but he really wants to kind
of more make it in the art world i guess
so
he's trying to like take pictures of
like crimes taking place and stuff like
that so he can have stuff to sell the
newspapers but then his girlfriend
through a mutual friend of theirs sets
up a meeting with uh with him and this
woman named i think her name is susan
and she's played by brook shields
actually who's kind of like a big time
like art agent and if or a gallery owner
or something like that she's kind of
like one of the taste makers like in the
new york city art scene and if she takes
a liking to his stuff then you know
maybe that can be like a whole career
now like in art instead of having to
like you know sell sort of ambulance
chasing photos to the tabloids
so he goes and meets with brook shields
our susan brother i'm just going to call
her brook shields because it's a brick
shield brook shields looks great in this
by the way um yeah so he goes and meets
with her and she looks at his photos and
she's just kind of like man these are
all right but you know she's like they
don't have like a lot of oomph to them
she basically shouldn't say this
outright but she basically says you know
maybe you're playing it too safe uh the
photos that you're taking maybe
you know you kind of get these
interesting photos but maybe you should
have kept shooting like when some like
even worse [ __ ] was gonna happen and
you'd get like more of a visceral uh
kind of photo so you know come back to
me when you have you know some more
exciting [ __ ] than this
so he really uh kind of takes this to
heart
and whereas previously he'd kind of been
just wandering around the city taking
pictures and as i said seemed to be like
kind of playing it safe in the sense
that um you know he wasn't like chasing
people around or like you know going
into super dangerous situations or
anything like that you know he was
basically just taking pictures from like
far away and like sneaking around and uh
so he wasn't really getting all up in it
and he was doing it during the daytime
so what he starts doing is he starts
prowling around the city at night
looking for
essentially kind of dangerous situations
or sketchy situations that he can sort
of insert himself into to get some
exciting photos one of the things that
happens like the first thing that
happens is that he's um going down uh
into the subway one night and there's
this one this young woman down there
this beautiful young woman and she's
being accosted essentially like
assaulted by like three or four guys
uh in the subway station so he starts
taking pictures of it and i'm sitting
there going like are you gonna like help
that girl or what now but he does take a
bunch of pictures uh but then he does
actually intervene
and he calls out to them like hey what
are you guys doing or whatever and they
actually threaten him and he gets some
pictures of that too but then he's
basically like hey you don't want to do
anything to me because you know the cctv
cameras are right there and it's like
they've seen your face and all this
other stuff so the guys actually wander
off
and the young woman is very grateful um
you know she's like you know thank you
so much most people wouldn't have
intervened like you did and he's like
yeah i did this time and stuff like that
and he got some good pictures out of it
you know
and uh so she goes to get on the train
and uh so she gets on the train and he
sees like some some other guy on the
train
and he just sees his hand like with the
ring and you know when he's taking
pictures of her
and then the next day he sees in the
newspaper that the very young woman that
he saw get on that train like it at
whatever time it was it was like two
o'clock in the morning or something um
so it was like a really late train he
saw her get on there it's like she has
since disappeared
now because he had this picture of her
getting on the train and there was this
random person's hand with a very
distinctive ring on the finger he's like
well basically i need to go to the cops
because this person with this ring might
have been the last person to see her
alive or you know might have been the
person that that uh made her disappear
let's call it that
so he goes to the cops they seem a
little dismissive and they're basically
like well why didn't you help her why
you know why were you taking pictures of
her were you stuck you know so they kind
of make him seem like more of the guilty
party he's just kind of like well
whatever if you want to do something
about it all these people have been
going missing and it's like i'm just
trying to help so whatever i'm a
photographer and i was just trying to
take pictures as it goes on uh in new
york city there have been a series of
people disappearing
from late night subway trains now i
believe that you know what's going on
like pretty early in the movie because
they do show
um
this
serial killer essentially who's played
by vinnie jones who's great in this
and he doesn't say a word and there's a
reason for that but
he doesn't say anything but he's just
like this big hulking menacing presence
i just remember seeing him in a lot of
like british crime thrillers he always
plays like a big scary gangster dude it
seems like all the time which type
casting but you know what are you gonna
do that's what he looks like and that's
with the kind of work he gets but yeah
so vinnie jones is basically playing a
serial killer who you find out later his
name is mahogany and he just uh rides on
this train like the very last train of
the night and whoever happens to get
into the same car with him uh mahogany
just goes up and essentially butchers
them in really really
horrific gory ways like i said now the
special effects on this because a lot of
the um the blood flying and stuff like
that is cgi and it does look kind of
like cgi like sometimes you know like
sometimes in the early seasons of the
walking dead it kind of looked like that
so it kind of looks like that but
it doesn't really take too much away and
honestly i will say that like the
violence and the gore and stuff in this
is actually like really good like i
really like
the um because you a lot of times he
uses mahogany will use like a mallet
like there's one point there
ted raymie actually has a cameo in this
and he gets like one of the best deaths
because like mahogany like hits him in
the back of the head with like with this
big mallet and his eyeball just kind of
like pops out like in three months it's
like pretty cool and also there's one
too where like a girl gets beheaded and
they almost do like severed head cam
where the head's like where you're
seeing things from the point of view of
the severed head and she's looking back
at her own body and it's just it's
almost kind of like you're her soul like
leaving the body like it's in her head
and that's leaving so it's like i really
really like that there's like a lot of
really good like gory shots like that
so essentially um leon the photographer
he starts getting more and more
intrigued by
this
hulking person who he suspects may have
something to do with all of these people
going missing um and like i said they
haven't found any bodies or anything
like that but just all these people have
been disappearing like from the subways
so he starts to suspect there's
something and the pictures that he took
that night um of the thugs that were you
know kind of uh harassing that woman and
the ones of the woman and stuff and then
some of the ones that he took of
mahogany from kind of far away like he's
just this really menacing figure he
actually shows them to susan or to
brooke shields character and she's just
kind of like oh this is more like what
i'm talking about you need to come up
with a few more images like this and
then we can i can put you in one of my
group shows and you know maybe that'll
like kind of jump start your career and
everything like that so he basically
just starts going out every night like
looking for
you know stuff to take pictures of
dangerous stuff to take pictures of and
because he's become so convinced
that this
dude that he keeps seeing who always
looks like he has this like this
immaculate suit and he's always like
carrying this briefcase or whatever and
he's like so he sees this guy every
night like getting on the late train
and he's like there's this guy has got
to be you know something to do with like
these people missing so he starts
essentially following him around he
follows him to work he works at like a
butcher a meat processing plant or
something like that and so he just
starts following he tries to take
pictures of him but then
you know the guy sees him and he's like
starts intimidating and stuff now during
all of this uh leon's girlfriend who he
has sort of proposed to well he's like
they're like engaged to be engaged like
he gave her a ring but he's like well
it's not really an engagement ring it's
almost like a pre-engagement ring
because i guess he thought it wasn't
expensive enough or i don't know what
his deal was with that but um but yeah
so
so they're that they're having that
whole thing but as he starts getting
more and more obsessed with this butcher
guy and he's just been going out every
night following him around and
you know the whole dark room like he's
looking for
uh you know old articles about about
murders that took place like going back
100 200 years something like that like
other people disappearing off the
subways and maybe he starts to think
that there's some kind of related that
you know sometimes the crimes are
related like maybe one's a copycat or
something like that so he starts getting
pretty much obsessed with it at which
point she's just kind of like man you
need to like knock this off it's like
one you're gonna get hurt two you're
like you're not sleeping you're not
eating um you know you just become
obsessed with this one thing and so
there's that whole situation happening
too and then one night it so happens
that he ends up getting confronted um he
actually as the story goes on he
actually does see
firsthand mahogany butchering of i
believe it's three people it's like two
guys and a woman that are together uh in
the train car and he gets some
photographs of it at which point
mahogany like attacks him and doesn't
kill him he just like knocks him out and
kind of like puts him uh you know back
in this
like dumps him in a subway station but
he takes his camera away so now he
doesn't like have any proof
and so the fact that he goes back to his
girlfriend and their mutual friend who
would you know set them up with the uh
art dealer at the beginning whose name
is uh jurgis um so so they get back to
him and he's like look i took pictures
of it the guy took my camera and so the
girlfriend and jurgis the girlfriend's
name is maya right yeah i think her name
is maya so maya and jurgis get this idea
to break into this dude's apartment
without telling leon to get the camera
back because they're starting to believe
that maybe there is something going on
and maybe this guy really is a murderer
um or something so they need to go get
his camera back so they break in jurgis
gets uh you know kidnapped and all this
other kind of stuff so now this is going
to be spoiler because i kind of feel
like maybe how you feel about this movie
is going to depend on how you feel about
the direction that it goes in it's not
different like if you read the short
story it's pretty much the same uh kind
of deal you know in the short story and
like i said spoiler alert spoiler alert
the story came out in 1984 so don't get
to don't jump on my ass too much it was
a long time ago but in the story it's
basically the same thing it's like this
mahogany
is just like
one in a long succession
of
people who have taken this train
and basically what there are are these
in the short story i think they're
called the elders of new york city
they're kind of like um just these
ancient god like demon like sort of
beings that sort of like run the city i
guess um and they live underground and
they are cannibals like they eat humans
so they kind of had it worked out with
some of the big high up city officials
it's like hey if you give us x amount of
human meat you know every day or every
night then we'll then we won't pop out
and like eat all of you so that's kind
of like an appeasement sort of thing
and so they always have
one person who's like a butcher who has
to who's kind of like doomed to ride on
this train
and kill people and hang them up on the
meat hooks and then the train goes down
to the underground lair you know where
the demons are or whatever and then the
demons will eat them and it keeps them
down there so it's supposed to like keep
everything separate so they have like
this whole system worked out and it's
been like that for a really long time
and that's essentially what happens in
the movie too so it's almost kind of
like mahogany even though from the
beginning you think this is like a
serial killer type story which it kind
of is
but leon starts following and trying to
solve the mystery of this quote-unquote
serial killer but it turns out that
mahogany is only doing this because he
sort of like got roped into it however
long ago it was and now he's cursed and
the reason that he never talks is
because when you take over this
thankless job they basically pull your
tongue out because you're supposed to
quote unquote servant silence i don't
think they say that i don't remember if
they say it in the movie but they do say
it in the story
so that's what they do like when you
when you are recruited into this job of
like
killing humans you know x amount of
humans per night to feed to the
whatever like the creatures that are
underneath in the book i think they were
more like
i don't remember if they were like
people people but they were just kind of
like i don't know demigods or demon type
things in the movie they're much more
like your standard kind of like
creaturey demony reptilian type of
things with claws and everything but
it's like you know the end result is the
same it's kind of like the same concept
so because you know early on um you know
well fairly early on you know probably
about halfway during the movie like
through the movie that mahogany is not
really like he looks like a human but
you can tell that he's not really
entirely human because it's like at some
point he kind of like pulls his shirt
open and there's all these really gross
i don't even know what they're supposed
to be i don't know if they're supposed
to be like nipples or tumors or
something like that there's all these
like black squishy like things all over
his chest and the nasty thing is that
like he cuts him off and then like he
puts him in a jar and keeps them like i
don't know why he keeps them but he just
has he has him like all these jars it's
like super disgusting
but yeah so there's there's that whole
issue but so you pretty much know where
this is going like once leon twigs onto
the fact of like what's going on and
starts taking the picture you know that
um that he's leon's gonna be the next
one because you've seen like over the
course of the movie that mahogany
is kind of getting um
i don't know i don't know if they really
it's almost kind of like mahogany is
he's either getting too old to do it or
you can only do it for so long before
you start breaking down or something
like that every now and then they have
to like get a new one and so you can
tell that leon because he's so
interested in this and because he's
invested so much of his time now to
following mahogany around and figuring
out what's going on that he's gonna have
to be the next one and indeed that is
what happens like um leon actually ends
up
uh you know they end up killing mahogany
and mahogany is just kind of like almost
kind of like happy about it like he's
just like like he's been released or
whatever because like i said it's kind
of like a curse and so leon gets taken
to this underground thing his tongue
gets torn out he um he either has to i
think like he has to watch the uh the
train conductor who is also in on it
pretty much kill his girlfriend and tear
her heart out and then you know he eats
it and like you know so so it's this
whole thing so now he's kind of like
doomed to become the subway butcher just
like mahogany had been doing for however
long he'd been doing it so as i said
this is kind of like honestly of all the
clive barker adaptations that i've seen
other than hellraiser i think this is
actually
unless there's one that i'm like not
thinking of but of all the ones i've
seen i think i like this one the best
like second after hellraiser like
hellraiser that's like in a league of
its own that's obviously the best one
but this one's pretty damn good i mean i
just really really liked
like i said the acting in it vinnie
jones was like so good at it he was so
good as like mahogany like i said he
doesn't say anything
you know his body language and his
facial expressions his eyes and
everything like that he just kind of
he's like very stoic but he also like
gives a lot of stuff away
um you know just the way that he moves
and things like that and he's very like
intimidating and scary but he's also as
the story goes on you almost kind of
start to
feel sorry for him a little bit because
it's kind of like he
you know i don't know if he volunteered
for this kind of stuff or if he just got
roped into it and i mean leon didn't
really volunteer either he didn't know
what he was volunteering for obviously
so he just kind of got ripped into it
too so you can tell if these people
didn't really want to do this but you
kind of don't have a choice like once
you've getting gotten tagged like tag
you're it you're like the next subway
butcher whether you like it or not so i
guess that's just kind of so so you kind
of have to feel sorry for them because
now every night they're gonna have to
ride this train
and help for however long and you know
kill random people come on there hang
them up on the meat hooks get them ready
for the city elders or whatever and it's
just kind of like a pretty shitty
existence also there's kind of i was
watching um
a guy like ryan hollinger and he had
done a um
kind of a breakdown of this and he was
talking about how
the theme of the movie is kind of like
kind of like voyeurism and kind of like
how easy it is to just sort of like
detach because i kind of feel like
that's
maybe what um leon's character at the
beginning
because he was so he was playing
everything so safe because he was just
taking pictures of everything from like
arm's length from like a you know
distance he didn't want to get up in
anybody's face he didn't want to get
involved in anything and he was just
trying to like take pictures from far
away so then when the art dealer said no
you need to get like in the mix you need
to
you know keep shooting like even when
shit's getting dangerous and stuff she
doesn't say exactly that but that's kind
of what she means um
and then so he starts doing that and
it's almost kind of like exciting but
then in the end he ends up getting like
way more than he bargained for obviously
um you know what i mean so it's almost
kind of like just this really
interesting voyeurism involvement kind
of theme and i just like really liked it
but yeah so if you like clive barker if
you like the original story um
and you've seen this like let me know
because like i said it seems like this
got a lot of mixed reviews but i think a
lot of the mixed reviews came from
people who
didn't like that it took a little bit of
a monstery
supernaturally sort of turn at the end
but this the short story the original
short story did that too so
i'm not really sure why
anyone was surprised i mean obviously
you'd be surprised if you hadn't read
the story and then it to you it would
seem like what the [ __ ] this monster
[ __ ] is just coming out of nowhere but
if you read the story then essentially
the short story was the same like they
were feeding the human meat to these
underground creatures the chud or
whatever they were it was that kind of
thing so it's so it wasn't a shock if
you'd read the story but of all the
cloud barker adaptations like i said
this is actually a really really good
one and i was surprised actually
and how good this one was i mean just
the cinematography looks great like it
looks rolled it's real slick and it's
real um like i love all the shots of
like the empty subway uh you know this
empty subway stations and stuff like
that acting was great in it bradley
cooper was great in it it's just
i don't know it was just like a really
really good kind of mystery
slash monster movie and then it was like
had like some real over-the-top gore
effects that i thought were great like i
said the beheading the eye popping out
just like really really fun and like i
said it seemed like um
a shame that
because of i guess studio politics or
whatever it was this kind of got a
little bit
you know like i said it was 100 theaters
that's all it was released in and then
they're like yeah just kick that off to
dvd and you know we'll see what happens
and you know so i so i kind of feel like
it fell through the cracks a little bit
and like i said it's kind of a shame
because
uh this is actually a really really
decent horror movie and it's a really
really decent clyde barker adaptation so
this is actually on 2b for free now if
you want to watch it uh at least as of
this recording so uh let me know if
you've seen it what you thought about it
if you liked it if you didn't like it if
you read the original short story um you
know if you're a fan of clive barker and
which of his adaptations uh movie
adaptations is your favorite just let me
know in the comments and we'll have a
discussion about it and that will do it
for this flickers of fear and i will see
you guys on the next one bye